how has the beef online with Hans
evolved since the last time we spoke
it's evolved it's evolved uh he has uh I
guess we've been uh in different ways
trolling each other to for a while I
posted a couple of things he posted a
few things he had a MC Vader do poster
for his solo shows using my face and
name and uh that was interesting then I
reposted that then he gave me a strike
down copyright notice on Instagram so I
screenshotted that and posted his notice
which I no is from from his cuz it said
it's handk with his handk email you know
what I mean so it's like I know I knew
it was directly from him and then but he
still has blocked me but somehow things
get to him or he reopens his Instagram
from time to time to check things I
don't know he's been uh insulting fans
of mine that put comments about me on
his channel it's just like it's being I
wish it had been a little more fun I
wish he was able to take the joke but
he's taking it incredibly seriously and
I hope that translates into him finally
writing some good jokes for that show